please give a warm welcome to kelly
rowland
hi kelly how are you
so good you know i always love seeing
your lovely face
i love seeing you too i just saw myself
on the monitor i didn't even have a face
because it was so scrunched up and a big
smile i was like
kelly it's so nice to see you
i'm happy to say that we meet up here
and there on
baby to baby um which is
a charity that kelly and i are both
angels
um you're on the board yes and um
it's such an important organization it's
a company that really takes care of
children and their families most
importantly you can go on our website to
see
the place that kelly and i both have in
common
and work with and i've always loved that
we have that connection because it's
such a meaningful one
but there's another meaningful
connection that we have as well
and that is that uh you're a producer
and i was lucky enough uh to get to
produce the charlie's angels movie
and i will never forget
the moment where mcgee our director
walked into the trailer and he was like
i have really big news
and he told us about the single and how
we were going to get to collaborate with
you guys on an original song
but i will never forget when he brought
in
the video and we got to see you guys on
your motorcycles and
what was so amazing was the symmetry
of the three women and the three women i
always think about it as corners like
everybody has
each other's backs in this weird
interesting way
you know what i mean like there's no
blind spot i feel like
physically there's no blind spot and
three it was
it's just the magic number i feel like
with women um
that was one of the best moments of my
career for sure
i it really was for us too and
you guys also said our names in the song
because that's just something that isn't
done and you made that such a unique
signature and i do think it really
grounded it it wasn't our characters
names it was our real names and
when music and film comes together they
might have a similar title or a theme or
say from the motion picture
soundtrack but you guys knew to humanize
it
and really put yourselves in it and it
became like this
mirrored sisterhood that was just so
cool and
can i ask like fly on the wall were you
guys
having certain conversations what was
like you know
the musicality discussion or the lyric
discussion or
you know what was that like
um i just remember we wanted to have
tags
you know what i mean at the beginning of
the record
um as far as you guys as names were
concerned and
of course being the stars of the movie
like we had of course respect and
just wanted it all to feel just unified
you know what i mean i just feel like
when that moment
happened in the studio it it all clicked
into place
it was just about us having this like
you said
symmetry um amongst uh the six of us
basically
on on the record and it happened
cameron d and destiny like charlie
come on with my girl
drew
[Applause]
um now pivoting back to
babies um congratulations on your second
pregnancy
thank you
there is something that you share with
your son titan
um i love that you write affirmations
on his mirror do you have any examples
because
i think that is such a cool
mom hacked life hack guru hack
how did you come up with this idea i
mean
i i do do it with myself so i figured
if i do it with myself then how much
more
um just amazing is it that he would be
able to have that and he's
i i started doing it when he was four so
um you know i just wrote it down on his
mirror with the little
markers little crayola markers just said
uh well you know um
i am smart i am
strong i am bold i have
courage you know what i mean and it's
like just simple ones and every week we
would change them
and then the next time it would be i am
a strong black boy
i am a smart black boy i am like it just
i wanted him to get it into his body to
where he absolutely has
no doubt to where if somebody were to
call him a name he's like
no that's not what the mirror says every
morning i have to say i feel like it's
really one of the best mom-wise
empowerment hacks i've ever heard of and
i'm gonna put it into practice right
away
okay so if i gave you one you have to
give me a mom
because i'm actually really nervous drew
about part two well
it's interesting because mine were so
close together i think that
there's always like a benefit to close
together because you're kind of getting
it all done and using the same stuff and
you know sort of moving forward in
tandem and then
if you i didn't have an older child
which titan is what he's he five may i
ask he's six years old now so it's six
years apart why did i wait so long
no no here's the thing
they're both win-win for this very
reason now
i think that because titan can help
himself a little
he'll also be able to help you a little
and he'll be such a part of the process
of taking care and bottles and fisting
and that
and he's a vital part of this process
rather than who is this that just walked
in
it's true oh i'm i hope will you tell me
how it's going i'm just
okay good good good good
[Music]